Salut ! Aujourd'hui une vidéo
un petit peu spéciale !
J'ai toujours rêvé de commencer
une vidéo comme ça !
Je vais vous donner quelques
informtions, restez bien jusqu'au bout,
je suis persuadé qu'il y a
quelque chose qui peut vous concerner !
Et même quelque chose
qui peut vous faire halluciner...
[Musique Générique]
En ce moment, avec la tournée,
ce n'est pas évident, évident,
de sortir des vidéos.
J'en sors en moyenne
deux par semaine.
Je ne suis pas persuadé d'arriver
à en sortir une deuxième cette semaine.
Si c'est la cas, ne m'en voulez pas
ce sera pour gagner
en qualité.
Comme d'habitude, durant toute
cette période de spectacles,
je ne vous donne pas d'heure
et de jour de sortie,
donc : activez la cloche
pour être notifiés.
Si vous êtes abonné.
Si vous n'êtes pas abonné :
Abonnez-vous.
Et je ne vous redonne pas toutes
les dates de spectacle,
vous avez un lien dans la description
sauf que la dernière sera
à Nantes !
Et ça, ça risque d'être Ouf !
On se verra à la fin du spectacle,
je vous dirai tout ça...
une fois que vous serez là-bas.
Là, je suis chez moi pour
seulement 12 heures !
Le temps de faire quelques papiers,
cette vidéo et je repars.
Et je reviens de Londres
où j'ai fait faire ça
par un photographe qui s'amuse
depuis 5 ans
à prendre des photos qui
ressemblent à des lettres.
Donc, vous devriez être capables
de lire quelque chose là...
J'avais juste envie de vous
le faire voir.
Alors : 5 choses à vous dire !
[Chuchottant] La 4ème est Ouf...
Premièrement : je vous ai demandé
très récemment sur les réseaux sociaux
principalement sur Facebook
et sur Twitter,
si ça vous intéressait qu'on fasse
un live, parce que j'avais une idée de live.
Vous avez répondu oui en masse !
Je flippe clairement, techniquement,
de comment ça va se passer...
Mais on va organiser ça.
Je vous donne rendez-vous
le 16 avril pour le 1er live sur cette chaîne.
Alors, ce live aura un sens ;
Ça va être un jeu.
A base d'énigmes et...
autre chose.
Et c'est une idée que j'avais depuis
très longtemps en vidéo,
mais, du coup, ça n'avait pas tellement
de sens de le faire tout seul
ou avec un invité...
Mais en fait avec vous,
c'est juste génial.
Donc, rendez-vous
dimanche 16 avril,
je vous laisse me proposer
un horaire dans les commentaires,
pour voir un petit peu
ce qui arrange tout le monde.
Deuxième chose :
Où sont passés les résultats
de l'expérience mentale
numéro 2 ?
Ils arrivent !
C'est extrêmement long
à traiter.
Je sais : je vous l'ai déjà
dit dans une vidéo,
mais je ne veux pas vous
balancer ça à l'arrache,
ou avec des chiffres
à l'arrache...
Ça prend Ouf de temps.
Et avec les autres projets
à côté,
en ce moment, j'ai du mal
à traiter ces données
ça sortira dans le mois d'avril !
Et la date, je vais vous la donner
en vous disant quelles vont être
les vidéos que j'ai prévues
pour ce mois-ci.
C'est la première fois que
je vous fais ça,
vous dire un peu les vidéos
que j'ai prévues pour le mois.
Il va donc y avoir :
les résultats de l'expérience mentale N°2
Tout un Hack Life sur la mémoire
via une question que m'a posé Guillaume
à l'issue d'un spectacle.
Puisque, à chaque fin de spectacle,
on se rencontre, on prend des photos,
on discute.
Et des fois vous me posez des questions,
je dis : "Attends !"
"Je ne vais pas répondre à cette question,
je vais en faire une vidéo. "
Et sa question était très pertinente
pour créer un automatisme mémoriel
on en reparle bientôt...
Une vidéo sur une boîte magique
qu'on va ouvrir ensemble
il y a quelqu'un, du nom de Xavier
qui a fabriqué une boîte
spéciale pour moi.
C'est cette boîte là.
Il a passé 127 heures dessus
il y a une énigme pour l'ouvrir
et on va essayer de la résoudre.
Je vais refaire une story parce que
vous m'en avez parlé dans les commentaires,
je vous ai dit : "Ben ouais, ça vous branche ?
C'est vrai que ça fait longtemps..."
Et, apparemment, ça vous branche
donc je vais en refaire une.
Le live qu'on va faire le 16.
Un Boost Brain, comme j'en fais
régulièrement sur la chaîne,
sauf que là, mon guest,
mon invité,
c'est vous !
C'est une vidéo Boost Brain
interactive.
Pas en live, mais interactive.
Un Hack Life pour gagner un jeu,
je ne vous dis pas encore quel jeu...
Un petit peu de suspens...
Et une nouvelle vidéo de mentalisme
plus version "non verbale",
où on va parler des
mouvements du regard.
Avec ce qui a changé par
rapport à ça,
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut,
aujourd'hui, encore en déduire
d'une manière scientifique.
Ça nous fait déjà pas mal de choses,
j'espère que ce programme
va vous plaire.
Quatrième point !
Je vous avais dit que c'était Ouf...
le quatrième point.
Est-ce que c'était juste un truc
putaclic, pour cliquer ?
Non ! Il est Ouf.
Vous vous souvenez que j'ai
2 trophées des 100.000...
J'ai reçu 2 trophées pour
les 100.000
Et bien, je vais vous faire gagner
un des deux trophées
Voilà. J'ai pris la décision de me
séparer d'un des deux trophées
ça fait un moment que
je me demandais comment ?
J'ai trouvé l'idée.
Et c'est chez l'un ou l'une d'entre vous
qu'il va aller...
Quatrième point bis
avant le cinquième point :
Beaucoup m'ont demandé
quand est-ce que je ferai
la VideoCity
A priori, j'y suis samedi et dimanche.
Ce qui est sûr, en tout cas,
c'est que j'y suis samedi
par rapport ce qu'ils
m'ont envoyé.
J'ai du mal à avoir toutes
les infos,
donc voilà : samedi en fin
de journée, j'y serai, ça c'est certain.
Et donc, le 5ème et dernier point :
C'est par rapport à mon livre
qui va sortir le 18 mai
qui s'appelle :
"Votre cerveau est extraordinaire"
J'ai tout relu,
j'ai validé tout ce qu'il
y avait dedans,
toutes les corrections
ont été faites...
Évidemment, j'avais une idée
pour en faire gagner un
d'une manière originale...
Ça s'appelle :
"Votre cerveau est extraordinaire",
parce que je ne voulais pas
appeler ça, euh...
"Trucs de mantalisme"
ou "Devenez mentaliste"...
Vous connaissez déjà mon point
de vue sur ce genre de définition...
Mais je vous en parlerai plus longuement
dans une nouvelle vidéo
sûrement non-répertoriée,
un tout petit peu avant qu'il sorte.
Et si vous voulez faire les tarés
et le pré-commander...
Pfffuiit !
C'est dans la description.
Il y a déjà eu des pré-commandes.
Je suis choqué. A chaque fois qu'il y a
une pré-commande, je suis choqué.
Ça faisait depuis le 2 janvier que
je n'avais pas fait, comme ça,
un point avec vous.
J'espère que vous serez
au rendez-vous pour le live !
Je vous ai donné le calendrier
du mois d'avril,
vous pouvez me dire, aussi,
ce que vous aimeriez
avoir comme thèmes,
un petit peu pour le mois de mai.
Il n'y a jamais plus stimulant que
d'écrire des vidéos quand vous me donnez des idées.
J'espère vraiment que cette vidéo
sera vue par l'ensemble de la communauté
parce que là, il y avait
toutes les infos !
Donc, n'oubliez pas de mettre un like
pour qu'elle soit bien visible
dans les suggestions de tout le monde,
et puis abonnez-vous,
si ce n'est pas encore fait !
Et rendez-vous très bientôt !
Sûrement samedi,
j'espère...
Je fais tout pour !
Ciao !
[Musique générique de fin]